[Music]
the ig
i'd just like to add that this happens
to be my wedding anniversary
so my wife and i've been married two
years today so
let's hope this meeting runs smoothly
like the last 30 years
all right
um
our patrick could you please provide us
with carrick here
1.1
apologies please
i was going to say murray but his name
just popped up here so yeah
he's here
nothing dear lovely so we can move on to
1.2
which is a welcome and introduction
i'm just looking up at my screen and
i've got sandra
immediately to my left so shall we lead
off with you sandra please
thank you um hello
what are we meant to be introducing
ourselves yet again hello sandra
mybakuru
councillor i thought it might be the
people that are new to this meeting
but however hello everybody
everybody
covered so far
but the family's beat had it twice
but yeah
thank you
you're welcome
judith
you're still muted judith
unmuted
judith
um yeah practicing social isolation so
i'm managing to remain copied and curvy
debris
and uh
yep
just life goes on
thank you
caroline
carolina's back
caroline could you introduce yourself
please
no
we'll move on
tia is dutifully taking the minutes
thank you tia
wendy are you with us
i am i hope you can hear me
yep yep no i'm here um
i'm a coming to your exegetive
um hope everyone's doing well
thank you
murray
here everyone um
uh apologies if uh you must be at the
start there i was just helping um
hopefully john ben from doc will join us
just giving one or two emails from
people just getting on the zoom link so
i'm
working the front door as well but
facilitator for this lovely committee
and delighted to be here murray
john's here that's great good
andrew
kinnick
the northern zone manager
good to see you all here on uh
radio with pictures
okay
those of you remember that hey
aaron please
good afternoon aaron harvey our
community representative
right
john
it's uh john cook uh
and we've got martha there
you are i'm martha i'm also a community
rep
stephanie
uh you are on good stephanie
stephanie you're still you're still on
mute
hi am i here am i working now no no
you're live yes thank you
kiara team my name is stephanie sims i'm
a community
comms and engagement advisor at
environment canterbury apparently i need
to learn how to drive my technology
apologies for that
is fine
um
now this has bounced around martha we've
said hello to you haven't we
yes hello yep thank you all right
lisa please
kiara yeah i'm lisa jenkins i'm the uh
the
team leader for
freshwater planting at ecam
thank you lisa
now we've got
arapata and we talk to you sir
sorry hi i'm kate i'm a resource
management officer at
urban regional implementation at
environment canterbury
thank you
murray i've got a recorder there with no
person on it
we'll pass on that hi mr jefferson
that's the recorder that we use to audio
stream okay
we'll let that run
rocky uh
we've got emily there on an iphone
yes hi i'm a comms an engagement advisor
um for the northern zone under kim
right here thanks emily
thank you sophia
hirokojo so water environment advisor at
my mercury district council yeah and
sophie allen i don't know what comes up
as sophia
no no it's just i think it's the user
name for the council comes up there for
some reason yeah that's right
hello everyone yep i won't bother with
the video i'm ugly enough so yep i'm
here listening to you
thanks john
now somewhere in there hopefully she
hasn't dropped off but i saw annabelle
annabelle are you still with us
um
no title to my name uh resident rate
payer
excellent
thank you annabelle we will be coming to
you very shortly under item two
if you've got enough
patients will be with you shortly
right
is there anybody out there in cyberspace
that we have missed please
definitely
thank sorry
let's bring bounces as people put their
hand up so
my apologies
no problem
right
right yeah so caroline is
struggling is that right murray
it looks like it i've just suggested to
her that we'll keep an eye on the chat
and if she's got any questions or
or things she wants to add then
chat
will be the way
she feels gagged but we'll do the best
we can to include her as as we proceed
thank you
item 1.3
registrations of interest
do we have any advice
changes or updates please
none taken thank you
alrighty item two
i2 item two which is opportunity for the
public to speak
annabel i believe you are the only
member of the public who's joined us
today so it's a privilege privilege and
the floor is yours
great i feel very privileged
i feel like i'm snooping on something
quite official um i don't know mike have
you told them my story
no no no you come in with a clean slate
well that's the first
um i live over on fair inside i'm on a
rorke's road
i'm
on the very edge of
fenside's rocky
area i'm completely wet it's not dry at
all where i am so
i've been here 33 years and
um began a week project last year it's
always been
my desire to i'm quite an environment
environmentalist bit of a grainy
and
i have springs on like several springs
fresh water springs
on my property
one is pretty close to the house
and then i have some more out in the
paddocks i've got 25 acres and i'm
boarded by a dairy farm
and um developers just bought the block
the other side of me
i was under there's underground streams
um
i think they've been tiled in the past
my neighbours upstream of me so and it
flows through
creating quite
um
[Music]
again they never dry up
waterways um
so it's been my desire to do the right
thing because although the water begins
here and springs up here
it joins um the cass river
and cam river so it becomes everybody's
water and i have a responsibility to
make sure that
i
the water passes through my place in a
clean way
now that is um a challenge
uh several years ago i set about fencing
off the wetlands and i've had many
people visit
my property with my concluded so i've
had
sephora from ecan out several times
i've had i think is that murray from
the ue trust yuri to trust
uh
oh scientists so i wanted to know if
what i had was worthwhile protecting so
he came out and confirmed that yes
although severely degraded it is a
genuine wetland
so that sort of upped the ante a wee bit
to think oh gosh okay that is comes with
quite a bit of responsibility
when we were planted in the spring last
year i planted 2 000 natives
after fencing off
along waterways that are created by my
springs
and
started of planting off the native the
carrick sector and then
other native plants that i got from
southern woods um i guess what i want
support in i don't mind doing the grunty
work
and i find it difficult that the only
way that i know of to apply for
assistance and support is if you've got
a continuous hectare
now i've got a hectare of
fenced off areas but it's not continuous
and that seems a shame because i
definitely want to do the right thing
i also have a limited amount of
knowledge
and i really would like someone to take
me by the hand and say hey
here's your wetland this is what we're
going to do
because the my house here is
pre-1900 and the floorboards are
kaikatea so i suspect it's from mild
kahikatea locally
um
and so i would like to return that
ultimately long term
to kahikatea
but firstly i've got to protect
those waterways
i have found underneath a little
footbridge that i got from when the
docker used to go over
the road down the and the lovely council
people delivered it to my place um
little wood freshwater
mussels
which i believe are incredibly talented
at purifying water but only exists in
shade so ultimately i have got to shade
those waterways
so hence this carrot sector
now i couldn't have chosen a better year
to plant
because
i haven't had to water a thing
so
the losses that i've got i was told to
expect a 30
loss
which i stubbornly refuse to accept
and has come to pass that nature has
provided and so my plants are looking
really good if not hidden
because the gra the growth is phenomenal
i've lost
a few plants but i think it's because
it's actually too wet which is ironic
um
yeah
i i want to know
how to do the right thing most
effectively so i just need
someone to take me by the hand and
really support me in that and i've got
it's been interesting because
the more you share
the more i feel i'm doing the right
thing and so many people want to help
i've had people out to help me plant and
make up the protector guards
and it seems timely that ecan planted
several hundred down here just near me
because i'm right where the cass river
comes in to rooks road by the way
footbridge
and so i've noticed that the planting's
gone on there where they've done some
stock bank repairs so that's really cool
uh eventually i would like to protect
that and have
public access but that's not that's a
wee way off
i'd sprayed um with buster which
recommended to me
um and i saw some russia's coming back
but i had
another friend come out who knew more
than me and identified them one was from
canada and one was from south america so
i was devastated
um
so yeah i'm
not sure where to go to next because the
water's gushing
it's spreading everywhere
and
yeah so that's my story
okay
thank you annabelle um
if i could just chime in with my two
cents
um
and i'm not sure about other zone
members
who are here
the time
or some of the time
you feel like you're banging your head
against the wall in this process and you
wonder are you making progress
because you get bogged down with plans
and
meetings and
and more plans
and recommendations about what's
actually being done
and a lot of what annabelle has done
is a physical action on the ground but
it's come about from
some of the pr work that's come from wdc
and ecan
that has spurred her into action to
recognize
as a landowner that she has a duty of
care for water quality
and that
gives me great hope for the
future so um that's my two cents
is there any committee members or staff
members would like to offer annabelle
a little
gem of knowledge or two
um judas please
i'm i'm putting on my
hi annabelle that's amazing project
there um i find that early biodiversity
trust hats here because that's the
perfect sort of project that trust is
going to be able to help with um and
though i don't know if you know much
about the trust
but we're only just phone i mean
literally a bunch of trustees we've
just
kind of been given some money by
wanakagura district council one can
actually employ a coordinator and
somebody to do exactly what you say
which is come along take your hand say
what about this here and this is how we
can do it
um
until we can employ somebody we are sort
of talking about looking and
looking for some project or something to
work with just so that we can be
bubbling along and finding out how to do
things and that might be something i can
uh i could talk to you off lying about
and just
just see how we can help
and just not be another group coming on
giving you another piece of different
advice that actually get us into a more
practical and perhaps bit more overview
sort of situation
um
my other suggestion would be yandu arts
and the
first 500 springs project
thank you
um i saw anna there briefly
who's joined the meeting
in a beltman
oh anna
uh
a bit of noise please
nikon
i mean there is this money for the first
500 meters downstream of the spring in
which
andrew has been
sending or allocating
we heard a lot about it probably
a year 18 months ago and i just wondered
if what's happened to those projects and
if there's still money there for 500
meters downstream of idols springs it
sounds like quite a lot of landing
because
andrew might be able to speak to that
yep okay so just
just to clarify first 500 was an
immediate was a subset of um
immediately
this program which has passed however
antebellum on full mechanics
i'm not getting any
he's frozen in time and for that matter
too we can probably chicken with um
with judith just to kind of round
everything out um sort of with the
diversity trust um and
yeah see what we can come up with and we
can actually help you out i just don't
know the site so we just need to you
know understand what that help what that
might take
lovely thank you andrew anna you're back
but you're still on mute
if you wanted
yeah i've only just changed i'm not
quite with the conversation right
okay now that's right but thank you for
joining the meeting
thank you thank you for having me
anyone else
sandra
thank you mr chair um well done
annabelle sounds excellent
who from my macaroni district council
have you been talking to
uh that was difficult um
i had been tried to get hold of kate
steele
yeah she's been unwell been very unwell
i and then when she did get hold of me
it was
uh yeah so
no that that really hasn't i just backed
off because i heard she was running well
really so
a couple of times and
we've tried to catch fish because we saw
a fish um so that was cool i have a
incredibly
healthy population of tuna the eel here
which indicates this water is actually
in pretty good house
which is really
encouraging
i was going to we have a um a contract
replacement for uh well doing some work
not a replacement but doing some work
that
that um
uh kate was doing
um i don't know whether you've spoken to
sophie ellen at all no
no
no sophia hello sophia so yeah so yeah
i'm not showing you sophia and that's
great yeah so i'm also at wamaker
district council um and we i do work
with kate and bex who's helping her out
part-time
but yeah we haven't been in touch so um
i i might better help um the only thing
that's the hitches i've got opportunity
leave soon so uh
yeah there's a constant change in this
world yeah
yes i was just going to say um what
you're doing fits in with a waimakariri
district council project called
arahatiyawa which is cherish the river
which is
public access planting protecting
waterways um the whole
kitten caboodle we're we're not up your
way at the moment we only started last
year
but um certainly um i can get your
contacts and be um
interested to get in contact and perhaps
go further because there are um
there's certainly the biodiversity trust
um which is
i
i don't know whether
as judah said not quite up and going to
the point where
well
they may be able to give you some some
informal advice
but certainly we want to put you on our
radar so that we can um
help as much as we um can help at this
the stage
so um well done absolutely excellent
what you're doing
yeah and i'll get your contacts and
we'll i'll be in touch and so i think
sophie impacts perhaps beck's dollar
from the council
so cool
i'm trying to put my hand up mike
that's right
can you hear me mike
yes i can okay um
the other piece of background is that um
i've i've grown up on a farm so i'm a
farm girl at heart
and
it
really upsets me to see
farmers not doing the right thing by the
land
and
so there's some work to be done with my
neighbours
and i thought by setting a good example
and talking with them that might have
some sort of positive impact as well
the place in front of me so this is a
this is just a little challenge i'm
facing
is a property
upstream of me
i would call it it's been just sold to a
developer and changed hands this last
week
so he has come to me and said that
because i'm not cleaning up my waterways
his paddock's flooding
and demanding that i clean it out now
that's been very upsetting
it was actually quite stressful and it's
very upsetting because the last time i
did that was at the request of the
previous owner and that's when i found
out about the eel the tuna
and
they were killed in their hundreds um i
spent a couple of hours returning them
to the water i know they're going to
make their way there but the birds had
arrived to eat the younger ones
um
so i have
inquired about the least
damaging way to do that now that's going
to disturb the sentiment the sediment no
matter what i do
but i
that's not flooding because of my
waterways it's flooding because there is
an intermittent spring in their paddock
but it can't flow anywhere because my
waterways are clogged with watercress
so i have agreed
because it's become a bit of an issue
actually in my place too to do one strip
but using a water rake so that things
like that that are really at the cold
face like how do i do the right thing by
the environment
but i've also there's flooding i mean
it's an incredibly unusual year
it's never happened like this before
ever even in the winter
and i also went onto some english sites
and then and in
a sister in denmark and they are now
finding residue of roundup in their
waterways
uh
and in england
you're not allowed to use any spray on
waterways now i've got
the wetlands with water everywhere
and it's the only thing that's fouling
it up is the ducks i just yeah i'm just
it's really hard
to do the right thing when everything
you think of doing is actually causing
damage to the environment
yeah
i couldn't agree more and about look at
this
layer upon layer of complex is the
complexity
um
anna
you're there
and you've got an incredibly good
practical background
of dealing with some of
these conflicting
parties have you got any thoughts that
might help annabelle
yeah look i have to be you have to
apologize i only just sort of tuned in
so i haven't heard the preceding
conversation and annabelle's whatever
she spoke about before so i'm a bit out
of context here be more than happy to um
meet up have a conversation i'm sorry i
missed the precursor to this
um michael i'm just wondering if you
know we've got a lot of offers of help
and different ideas now annabelle's
already had the number of these ideas
and
i could i offer the through the trust
partly to the design committee through
the trust to actually try and get
everybody together so we have a single
approach so
that'll be great i mean people might
visit her at different times but just so
that all these people know what that you
know what each other's doing and we get
a bit of a coordinated approach
possibly that's very concerned about
that's particularly this sort of
upstream neighbor
it is a lovely offer judas but i
appreciate you're still sort of in that
formative stage with the trust and it
sounds like annabelle's needing a wee
bit of advice
in the shorter term well i'm talking
about that now i mean the trustees are
operative it's just we don't have a paid
employee but we can help get the right
people there
and that was what i was thinking rather
than okay good how about we put you on
point
we'll put you on point and we'll get you
annabelle's contact details
and see what we can bring together
yeah that's pressure's on me so someone
was able to come out this week the next
few days would be fantastic
the pressure's on to drain that the
pressure's on to clean that's the
that's that's the immediate
pressure
um now there was a mess
up
sorry there was a message pop up from
our part of reuben to say he could
um help with the watercress straight
away i'm not sure what sort of volume
but
he might be just looking for a feed
i'm sure we could we could definitely
help the who get rid of that money
yep
there may be the stray hill that jumped
from me i don't know yeah yeah
all righty
how does that sound annabelle
that'd be great at the moment i've got
dean hurley booked in to come either
this thursday this friday or next monday
what do you think i should put them off
um
definitely defer him to as
far as you can without
upsetting your neighbour too much
um
but it's that tricky one um
given that it's intermittent spring and
this might be an ecan answer
then i would ask the question if it's an
intimate spring you're you're bordering
on an ephemeral waterway and that
possibly should be fenced if he's got
stock in there
yes
so then we start coming into
a whole
other issue
i have i have informed them that i've
had
ecan out and they've identified it as an
intermittent spring and
it has been the tiles went in drainage
tiles went in over 30 years ago so i've
been completely up front
but i also want to be a good neighbour
because the paddock is actually their
package is actually in trouble so
well well that's it
if both parties can work together
i think you can forge your way forward
rather than
blocking once too much okay so if you
contact me
um ringing i don't often answer my phone
but texts i always respond to so thank
you so much for listening to me has
anyone got any other questions otherwise
i'll leave you to it
lovely no that's great thanks annabelle
for your time yeah thanks everyone
bye
thanks annabelle
all righty
um
item three plant change seven and plan
change two
update
um
liqueur are you there
hello
is this video going good
um
everyone i introduced myself before my
name is luckil and i'll be joined today
by kate
so it looks like i'm not looking at you
because i have you on another screen
um
and i'll just get this presentation
going
while you're getting set up like you i
think for the rest of the committee's
benefit just to highlight that you've um
provided this presentation to the otop
committee earlier in the day as well
yes yep
and they had no questions so
both has been on the same day and both
being part of the sub regional as some
of you recall was a bit of a problem
resourcing through the process but um
online sessions has made it possible
today
absolutely
um
can you see the presentation that i've
shared here
yes yes
um and so just another thing is that we
might get you to hold your questions
until the end if that's okay just so we
can get through it in case we come to
the answer naturally on another slide um
also i just can't see any of the champ
function at the moment so
um if you want to leave something in the
chat that's fine um
i think murray is going to help us run
the questions
at the end of the presentation so if you
leave them there we will look back to it
or you could just hold it and
ask it yourself when we get there
lockheel another option and this is it
your um
you know whatever you feel comfortable
we could
given that we've been presented with
most of it take it as read and go
straight to questions but
um it depends what what your thoughts
are
yep oh so have you had a look through
the presentation already well we've
we've been given an overview
um
so um
i'm happy to do that the presentation
itself lakel so but but obviously the
supporting information that was on the
agenda
okay well we'll work through the
presentation really quickly because
there's a possibly a little bit more in
here than i put in the paper um but we
won't spend too long on it and then we
have a bit more time for questions at
the end there's only nine slides and two
other ones the title and one's the
insides
this
isn't actually
there
cool
so
i am starting with a bit of a summary um
like background information there
because i know the zone committees have
um
changed membership a way but over the
past few years and some of you might not
have been around for the start of plan
change seven
so when we say pc7 we are referring to
plan change seven to the canterbury land
and water regional plan or
that plan is also referred to as the
lwrp
um pc7 is comprised of three parts so
part a is the omnibus which makes
changes primarily to region-wide
provisions to better align the plan with
national direction so that's examples
like the plantation forestry topic and
also the omnibus section responds to
confined issues raised through
implementation of the operative
framework so
um pc7 introduced a new nutrient
management regime for commercial
commercial vegetable growing um
part b relates to the otops subregion so
we're not going to cover that here today
and part c makes changes to section 8 of
the plan which is the waimakariri
subregion
and those changes seek to improve
nutrient management improve flows and
allocation and also set a time frame for
consent reviews to implement those
changes
and to improve cultural outcomes
so we won't go into heaps of detail
about the plan change because i'm sure a
lot of you are familiar with it and the
decisions have been out for a few months
um
but if you have any questions do feel
free to ask them at the end
um
and often in the same breath as pc seven
we refer to plane change two which is
plan change two to the waimakariri river
regional plan
that's a change that's consequential to
pc7 so it removes an overlap where we
have two operative regional plans
applying
um and the slide you'll see on the left
we've got the green area which is
section 8 of the land and water regional
plan and we've got the blue area which
is the waimakariri river regional plan
well i think we're still
on your opening slide is that oh really
yeah now it's moving you might want to
i don't know if you want to click onto
slideshow
and
that's that's where i might be
so you've missed this one which is where
i gave background
can you is that plan change seven parts
yeah
that's right so you see yeah we've got
that now
we've seen the slides it slides at the
side as well which um
i wonder if you might be sharing the
wrong screen look he'll you might have
your oh
okay
i'm gonna
restart it if that's okay
this never happens on online sessions
that's looking yeah i think you're
how's that look now
everyone
oh too far
i've nailed my presenting in teams but
zoma is like a new
new realm
so we on the planet two slides
you've got my slide but not the notes
but not the notes correct cool perfect
thank you for that murray
um
so oh
where was i so the map on the left um
you can see
there's an overlap between the green and
the blue where we've got the green which
is section 8 of the land and water
regional plane applying and the blue
which is the weimar community river
regional plan applying so the purpose of
plane change tow to the waimakariri
river regional plan is to remove
that overlap so only section 8 applies
and the waimakariri river regional plan
will continue to apply to the main stem
of the river and the upper catchment
including its headwaters
and an area of land south of the
waimakariri river
so this is
that moved for you
yes yeah cool
thank you um
[Music]
and a wee bit of background on the
process here is um
going back a wee bit earlier than what's
on the slide the one which part of pc7
was largely based on and informed by the
work that the song committee did working
with your community and finalizing the
zone implementation program addendum or
the zipper
um that was presented to councils in
late 2018 and then ecan notified plan
change 7 in july 2019.
they well our council also appointed an
independent hearing panel to hear
submissions and evidence and make
recommendations back to the council
and
initially the hearing was delayed a few
months due to coverts meant to start in
may 2020 um but it did get off the
ground in september 2020 and then closed
with the reply hearing in february 2021
and then the council's decision was also
initially delayed that was due to the
impending
anticipated release of the overseer
review reports so the minister of the
environment granted us an extension to
the time frames for making
our decision well the council to make
its decision
and um the council notified its decision
to adopt the recommendations of the
hearing panel in full in november last
year
which brings us to the current stage of
appeals
slides keep getting a bit stuck
so
appeals
because pc7 was notified under the ecan
act our appeals were limited to
questions of law and not questions of
merit
and appeals were lodged directly with
the high court of new zealand
um five appeals were lodged on pc7 and
they've all had interested parties
during the proceedings plainchange2 did
not receive any appeals
so provisions
not under appeal are now beyond
challenge and can be treated as
operative
and you can find copies of the notices
of appeal so that kind of provides the
scope or what um people have appealed um
on the plan change seven webpage and
that also gives a list of the interested
parties that have joined
and there's some information about the
which provisions ecan considers to be
under appeal
in terms of how appeals affect the
implementation of pc7 and the zone
one of the appeals was on region-wide
plantation forestry provisions which if
you're looking up as the ryanair and
port blakely one
and the other one
which is relevant would be the appeal
lodged by
onotahu and
arafenoa um and that touches on the
deletion of the mahangakai allocation
from the i'm sorry the ymca flow regimes
as well as low top flows
so
we can't give a definitive timeline for
how long it might take for appeals to be
resolved because it's not actually a
process that akan runs that's that's the
high court her in charge now
what i can say is that as an indication
it's taken about one year so 12 months
give or take in the past for appeals on
previous plane changes to be resolved
and when they are all resolved we will
make plane change seven and plane change
too operative hopefully no definitely
um
to answer the nitrate priority area
slide here um
murray did send us few
send us through some of the questions
that the committee had in december when
the decision was notified um so we've
tried to address them
here
i'm sure there'll be more that come up
later
so the nitrate priority area provisions
are not under appeal which means they
will be treated as operative from now
um the decision
in terms of difference from what was
initially notified in 2019
um the decision found a need for early
and more stringent reductions in
nitrogen limits so that increased the
reduction in 2030 to be 20
um
losses
20 below gmp across all the nitrate
priority areas and then a second step in
where nitrate losses would be 30 below
gmp and we just want to emphasize that
that's that's 10
more
than 20 30. it's not
um
well 10 less than 20 30 sorry it's not
30 less
so they
their numbers sort of
build on each other but they don't
multiply each other i don't think that
was the best explanation but um i can
clarify it later if that didn't make
sense
um
the decision also removes the last four
stages um but it does retain signals for
further reductions in the future
um and the policy so
sort of
section 8.4 the policy provisions um
signaling also a need for ongoing
monitoring and assessments downstream
um
of the impacts of
on the river and on the christchurch
deep aquifers
it also retains the different sub areas
even though they've all been treated the
same in the provisions in plan change
seven
now that those further reductions have
been removed
um
and then the other thing to say here is
i'm sure there's going to be questions
about overseer and unfortunately there's
not a lot that i can add
to that question at the moment um
it's the overseas question is one that's
like relevant to pc7 and how it will be
implemented but plan change 7 doesn't
actually use or refer to oversee it in a
way that's different to how the
operative plan does
so the solution to the operate operative
plan
will be applied to pc7 in the same way
i think we're making progress on getting
an interim solution agreed uh hasn't
quite landed with all the vernanga
throughout canterbury but um
where it has been agreed which i'm
pretty sure is the waimakariri's own
zone
the council should be in a space to
start implementing that solution soon
and
a good place to look for information is
also just the ecam website there is a
page on overseer and that is where the
most up-to-date information is always
going to be
my last slide before i hand over to kate
is you should be looking at the regional
planning framework steps
um
so
one question we get with well we've had
since
2020 when the freshwater package was
announced was
if we have to notify a plan or a plan
change that's compliant with the
national policy statement for fresh
water management by the end of 2024 why
bother with pc7
um
so for starters we still need to
implement a plan while that new
framework has been developed and then
goes through its own hearing process
so
that's a minimum of four to five years
that we're still going to need to be
implementing the lwrp
and
plane change seven
is a massive step in the direction that
we need to be taking
so
keep wasting my space in my notes sorry
um
we're moving in the right direction with
pc7 and like i said we need something to
do in the meantime and hopefully the new
framework can build on the great work
that's already been done
and the zone and for the zone so
we won't be starting from scratch um
osho and makuri actually have sort of
the most recent science
um
and work like that kind of work that's
already been done in the past few years
so we'll definitely be looking to build
on that rather than start from scratch
with the new framework
now
handing over to kate
hello i'm sorry i just pulled out my
notes when i unmuted myself they
disappeared
here we go um
so as mentioned i'm kate um i'm working
to implement pc7 within environment
canterbury um
this implementation is a bit of an
ongoing process at the moment and
we're working with relevant sections
within environment canterbury to ensure
a consistent approach is taken and
ensure we're able to provide accurate
information
to consent holders to stakeholders or
really anyone that's um
involved
in the implementation slash carryout of
pc7 and
we're also aware that some of the
changes in pc7 are also regulated in the
essential freshwater regulations
well
they're not really they're not the same
changes and they're not the same
legislation we need to be looking at a
lot looking at them alongside each other
um
to make sure we're giving you the most
kind of the most comprehensive um and
providing you with the best advice and
information available um especially when
it comes to which one you need to be
looking at or like looking at them
alongside each other and determining
which regulation
is kind of the the strongest um
which is generally the one you go with
um alongside the work that's being done
internally we're also working with hort
nz
to identify land which is being used for
commercial vegetable growing within
canterbury
this will ensure we're able to
accurately inform decisions around
discretionary activities at namely rule
5.42 cb which identifies the total area
of land use for commercial vegetable
growing
in the nutrient management area and the
canterbury region as a matter of which
discretion can be applied
um
so this will basically
when we know how much
how much land is used for commercial
vegetable growing we can then determine
what percentages of it are
able to be consented in the future
so this will be instrumental in ensuring
we're able to meet the requirements of
pc7 when issuing consents
we don't have a confirmed date on when
this will be up and running but
hopefully
asap
and that's all from me if you've got any
questions feel free to let me know or
look i'll know
lockheel kate thank you for that
presentation
um questions from the floor please
judas
thank you very much for um
both lucky and kate um
one thing that didn't seem to come
through was the tremendous pressure from
the mps fresh water
and the sort of understanding of
conflicts between that and some of the
things in the pcc
um and how econ is going to deal with
that you know you talk about giving the
best information the best advice but
it's actually some real nitty-gritty
um
yeah implementation work to be done to
tease them on why not tease them apart
knit them together isn't that just
wonder how that's going
yeah it's something that's definitely um
occurring at the moment and there are a
lot of conversations about it in the
implementation space
i'm not sure if raquel you have a better
answer um
than this but basically we're working on
it um and we'll have answers as soon as
we can
um but at the moment we just i'm working
through everything
yeah i think it's a very wishy washy
answer
so
i know that some of the team have done a
lot of work on um not just pc7 but the
operative lender water regional plan
like a big conflict assessment there so
conflicts and stringencies trying to
identify any instance of
either of those happening um
in any of the other plans and pc7 just
is running a bit behind that because
it
it doesn't make
we kind of we needed the council to make
the decision to know that we needed to
do the work on
the recommendations if that makes sense
um
i think
yeah unfortunately like kate said we it
does just have there is a lag to it
because we want to make sure we do it
once and we do it right
definitely underway
sandra's got a
hand up
yes thank you a question the main stem
of the waimakariri and the areas to the
south and the bits that um were excluded
from
pc7 how do they marry into your 2024
time frame for your total review
because we understood they were excluded
from the work the zone committee did to
inform pc7
and you're saying you know there's
questions about
okay why are you bothering this one
you've got to review the whole thing for
2024.
so is that review
for the main stem and the areas south of
the river still going ahead as a
separate exercise or
do they get
incorporated into your 2024
efforts
yep so
the whole region will be incorporated
into the 2024 efforts
yeah well what happens to
um
the bits that are excluded there were
chapters um in the existing regional
plan that were up for a review i.e the
main stem and the flows on the main stem
and the area south which you mentioned
so where did are they
still going ahead as a separate exercise
or do they merge into the whole 2024
deal
all right so that will merge into the
2024 um so the
planning
program um for the next couple of years
is
it's region-wide um
not
i think i sort of
i'm sorry i was trying to get my words
right so it's region white wide and so
there will be um
[Music]
i i don't know now how the consultation
and that kind of stuff is going to
happen um those decisions
are still being made um and there will
be consultation as we go but um it will
be the whole
the whole region
so those parts that haven't been
reviewed as past part of pc7 um will be
part of what we're looking at for 2024
as well as if pc seven doesn't go far
enough um
because i think that there were there's
quite a number of people who were um
who saw that it was essential that the
waimakariri river main stem
and input into that and we are waiting
for that section
right it's alpine rivers section in the
old plain from what i recall
so how are all the people that um are
waiting round for
giving input into that going to be
notified if it's all part and parcel of
the general
review to notify in 2024 bearing in mind
um
you know you're only talking we're
midway through 2022
and um
how how are everybody going to come
together for that because there are
people
wanting to um submit on that chapter
that hasn't been reviewed
i might i might be able to jump in and
and help you with that sandra thank you
um
um so
so yeah we are required by the mpsm to
review our entire freshwater plan
framework to give effect to the npscfm
by
and notify something by 2024
um so so that is happening
and yeah we're very aware that we're
we're now into 2022 and it feels like
there's there's only two years to go
before we're supposed to have that that
reviewed and we haven't done any public
engagement on that yet
um
what we're doing is establishing um
first and foremost
our partnership arrangements between
environment canterbury and the temp to
peru
and once it's established and we've and
we know how how we're going to be
engaging
um with manufenua
throughout this process
once that's kind of all in place we'll
be able to
then then start with an engagement
program
for um
the wider region
and it will be um
it's most likely that it will be
sort of
catchment based that engagement
yeah but it may not be at that kind of
same level of detail as as what you
might have seen in the in the last 10
years where we were spending
a couple of years kind of per
zone
um sort of
not nothing out that sort of really
gnarly detail will
probably had it at a much higher level
level of detail in the first instance
and then kind of come back for the
um
for the more refined stuff
later on
so how are the population how are the
people who want to
express their view
on these aspects going to
understand where you are in the process
we watch your comms plan i mean i
understand you're talking to the
um or the rooner um but
what about where's the where's the comms
plan for um public involvement
yep so the com the comms plan is
it has kind of can't be established
until we've got the arrangements between
manufa and
the regional council sorted but once
once that's sorted then we can sort of
we can
take the next few steps which is figure
out how we how we'll be engaging with
with the wider public and everything um
but they're you know we i guess
we are working on it but it's just
taking a bit longer than
it is just taking some time to get
moving because it is such a huge project
as well like it's it is um
you know
it is the scale of what we've done in
the last sort of decade we're doing
again
and
in a much shorter time frame so it's
just taking some time to get the
cogs in place i guess
okay thank you for that um have you any
sort of high level
information about when you will have the
um
the
consultation with manufa
sorted so that it will
um then go out um
wider and how i mean
how are we going to know this and how
are we going to tell our
residents and rate players that this is
underway
yeah i mean we don't we don't have um
any time frames on it other than we're
talking um
we are talking
the cat well councillors and manafort
are working really closely together to
um get it sorted as soon basically as
soon as we can
um but also knowing that you know
everyone's got a huge a huge amount of
um competing priorities at the moment so
it's yeah
you know is there any particular
um
e-can committee that this information
comes to that we can alert people to
have a look online is it in the is it in
the large formal agenda or does it go to
a particular committee
at the moment it's going through to
ropatoya
just as a suggestion to lisa just find
out andrew's query i i wonder too like
uh as the committee will be aware where
i've provided
particularly for this committee um pc7
updates sort of month by month as we've
met
and you know often they've been recently
incremental small changes but just
i've often conferred with lisa just to
kind of get what's where are we in the
process so
um i guess even with my team leader head
on i think if we continue to do that and
just provide an update on as we're
moving through the process that means
all the committees
and the therefore the tas as well are
getting informed as as we proceed
through
sandra's you know that's one mechanism i
guess of just even bringing it directly
to committees and councils
so if we just keep that pattern going
lisa yes thank you
i think we'd all appreciate that um
because not all of us are sort of um
getting all the information that we
might like to and there's clearly um
needs to be a
mechanism whereby
that's available or continues to update
so thank you for that
hi murray erin harvey here um i just had
a question in relation to uh i guess
was the
further investigations and monitoring
and modelling which might feed into the
the changing
um freshwater
framework for the planning
how
there's a both through the committee and
through other other groups are
interested in collaboratively
um
contributing to this monitoring to
ensure that what needs to be done is
actually done
but we
want to know or want to understand how
we can help make it actually plan
efficient for you so that it's useful
and informing both this planning
framework and any future
any future plan changes that may occur
yep
um so
i'm not a scientist so i could not give
any kind of details around that and i
think that um
sort of working with the ecan scientists
with
where they can provide support for that
kind of thing is probably the best way
to do it um
i think again sort of
because part of the national policy
statement for fresh water management
like does put um
it does have some requirements around
the monitoring framework for the plan um
so that is definitely
something we'll be thinking about over
the next couple years i'm sure science
already thinking about but it does um
i think just also
in terms of informing the next planning
process um look back away but to what
lisa was saying where
the first major step in that process is
to set up those partnership arrangements
with the papa tempurunga
um
before we can really start getting down
into some of that detail
yeah so you're saying that um we need to
just keep in touch with science and
maybe link back into yourselves once
you've progressed further with with your
relationship building there
yeah yeah
all right
thanks here any further questions
kate
with the question
from caroline sorry um how is he kind of
going to deal with the potential
requirement for all properties
pectess plus to have fresh water
sorry i'm not sure about other members i
i could hardly hear you judith
you're michael if you want me just to i
can re-read it sorry and thanks for
picking that up judith um yeah caroline
just asked the question around
how environment canterbury is going to
deal with the potential requirements for
all properties 20 hectares and above to
have a freshwater farm plan
so can can i
unless kate has anything to add here
that might just have to be something
that i um
have a chat to the essential freshwater
team and um send something back through
murray i'm
not
specifically in that space um working in
that space at the moment so i don't want
to just make up an answer
yeah no con
completely agree with you
so i'll um take a copy of that and come
back to you
i might be able to help just a little
bit
i know that um
what the actual government requirements
are going to be haven't been
haven't
finalized yet
so um
we are anticipating that we'll just get
something in regulation that we have to
implement
um
but yeah we don't really know when
that's going to be and or what it's
going to look like and until we kind of
have a bit more detail we're not going
to
we're just not gonna know i'm afraid
all right
thank you lisa um
i think we've probably kept this can
around the room enough so i appreciate
your presentation
and if unless there's anybody else out
there that would like to say something
i'd like to
make the recommendation that the zone
committee received this update
with roof with its reference
um
so i'll have a mover please
judith seconder aaron all those in favor
all right
thank you thank you
against
carried
thank you very much
staff for your time
thank you
alrighty um
3.2
murray i think you're running that one
indeed i am
michael um look i'll uh endeavor to
share my screen as well
and
hopefully
the committee if i can share i'll get
not sure
um i'm in the right place
i've got a sheer screen first
can you
see um
that powerpoint
opening slide can't even see you though
oh there we go that's
helpful
um let me get out of that
it's as liquid was saying
we've got very used to
teams but um hold on i'll just see if
i cancel all that
try again
[Music]
do that you can probably see yourselves
now if i do that is that
can you see the opening slide now from
murray you're sharing the wrong screen
you're sharing your screens come up when
your shirt
that's i've only got one screen
i'm just working on a letter
um t are you able to see i don't know if
you've got that
if i had another screen i'd share it but
i can i don't know quite
oh hold on
i don't know if that helps let me try
again does that look better i think i'm
sharing it now am i
can you see it yes there you go yeah
look at that
jay just got it
is that going back to the go back to the
lead um
slide
yes heading side yeah okay
that's great look so
we'll follow through with judith's um
slides and um i guess hopefully to make
this reasonably easy for us to sorry
obviously i've
sent you a 49
slide presentation just providing
overview of what are now six projects
that we're looking to
uh put forward
with regard to the 50 000
cwms action plan budget for this
financial year
um at the last meeting
so that's the recommendation that we've
got on that slide from
the meeting paper
and then the next slide of judith if you
go through
you'll see um
there that the other six projects that
we've got i've put that subtotal into
highlight for us
what we've presented at the previous
meeting back on 31 january so we had the
first four
there are two
small changes but um two changes to note
with the sums in those first four and
the first is a forty dollar change to
taranaki stream
uh in a spawning improvement which um we
had rounded up to eight thousand six
hundred
but um in doing the sums in the the in
the slides that follow on the um the
program budget you'll see that it comes
to eight five six so
um
accompanying that uh that the second
project the sift and saltwater creek
monitoring program as you'll see
noted there and you may have
recalled from my email or seen in the
further content and the slides on that
project that
carol and i had a discussion around that
project and
a candy way to get 000 comfortably was
to look at incorporating both year one
and year two of that three year project
into this year so changing it from
originally it was 3835
now it's
6640.
um the benefit of that
is that it allows carolyn and
the group to not only set up the
monitoring in the first year but also to
get underway and as caroline
highlighted and if she could speak to us
today she could speak to it um i think
some of the advice from the likes of
adrian meredith and others was
more and i'm sure everyone agree the
more monitoring you can do the better it
is so it enables the project to actually
not only get established but
a bit of um room to uh to do some more
monitoring if if
that is actually possible in the next 12
months so
so not only does that help from a
budgetary point of view but i think it
also helps the project significantly in
terms of not only getting underway but
also
well and truly establishing its
monitoring program so
those were the two changes um to the
first four projects since then we've
also added on
um as we workshopped in february the
ashi rakahuri rivercare group coming
forward with a estuary shorebird
monitoring program
around the saltwater creek and
rakahuri estuaries
and also the field trip we had
a couple of weeks ago with greg burns to
look at the pines beach wetland willow
control and and what is the longer term
plan for that wetland area
so consequently we have now got six
projects um
in the suite for this financial year
adding up to
precisely fifty thousand dollars based
on that contribution across those
projects so
um
i i maybe now's a good time for a
question for the committee do you want
to go through all of the presentations
or are we slight or we better
if there's any questions around any
particular projects if we take that as
read and
you know generally accept it in terms of
the way it's proposed and the content
information
mindful too that judith provided a wee
bit more
background this morning by email
on the
biodiversity trust's visioning workshop
so hopefully that was useful for the
committee
maybe michael we're better to
to go to questions and just see if
there's anything
uh by way of uh
you know if there's any further queries
or questions to to make the committee
comfortable with
supporting that uh
suite of projects in this financial year
yes murray that'd be my preference we've
kind of we have spent a fair bit of time
workshopping this so
questions would be my preference so
let's go straight there please committee
members do we have
questions from the floor with regard to
what's been proposed
and i'm sorry i've i've still got
judith's screen up so i can't see if
anyone's waving your hand if you want to
speak just
speak
caroline's confirmed that all looks good
to her so she's happy with what is
proposed
sorry judith
no i was just picking up caroline's
message
i think i heard it thanks arapata
yeah i think we've been through this
lots actually which is great i feel
really comfortable with it good all
right
i feel happy with it as well
okay
um well let's move straight to the
recommendation that we received the
information on the proposed
action plan budget
supporters for the 21
22 financial year
and secondly that we approve
these projects based on the fifty
thousand dollars
for the action plan
for that
um water for our water zone in that
period
all those in favor
aye
please
uh mr chairperson please could you just
have a mover and a seconder before you
go to vote uh my apologies here i can
move it uh
i'll second it
right so we've got murray
are you allowed to do it
no no it's john oh sorry
goodbye
sorry
we've got the same singing voice john
obviously absolutely man
you will scream please because uh yeah i
i cannot see
um
can i close this i'll close the chair
yeah i don't think we need that yeah
okay
now students right now now i feel like
i've got my fan out back
right so
tia did we get a mover and a second or
out of that
i've got giannis
but unfortunately
i do not know who segmented it
i seconded
okay thank you
thank you all those in favour
hi
all right
walker
against
carrick thank you
right
item 3.3 and we need
sophie and murray to take the floor
please
thank you michael um i'll perhaps um
defer to sophie but i can probably just
introduce this obviously what just was
sophie's
um
just getting online as well but the
obviously this is two quarterly
reports that we've pulled together
mindful that with the 31 january meeting
it was
difficult getting
a substantive report together just
in a week just given that a number of
people were still on leave
so um appreciate the committee allowing
us to do uh two quarters and one at this
april meeting and we
are scheduled to have the next committee
meeting on the fourth of july which um i
guess is is good timing for us actually
doing a fourth quarter
uh report as well so we'll work towards
that um we've obviously had a couple of
staff changes and and people on leave
too that's also um impacted
a capacity to reporting and i think some
of the reporting actually reflects that
um for instance the groundwater science
team they're still looking to recruit a
hydro geologist which is always quite an
impressive title in itself but
um
amber has very kindly been able to
provide the content that's in there and
in fact adrian was able to um provide
the content for the surface water team
too which was greatly appreciated and
something of a surprise um when he was
able to do that so
um
i appreciate their contributions given
that they're in slightly different
situations now and um uh but
particularly with the pc7 i it obviously
relates to what we've just talked about
with lakel
lisa and kate that uh
amber's as she's done over the last
probably a year or so is just
highlighted i guess in particular the
groundwater but more broadly the science
team's involvement
and you know ongoing involvement in pc
seven and that continues through loading
them into the questions we were asking
earlier on
i think that'll be you know be
maintained as a reporting item against
the zip addendum as we move into the
next stage of planning as well so
maybe that's a little enough from me at
this point i can perhaps hand over to
sophie if she's online
if she wants to
talk through the
mvc part
i'm happy to have it taken as read there
were some reports in the
land water committee that went into more
detail about the private well study
results and the
uh what else was it the other
biodiversity community biodiversity
funding for the
lanca trust for example so there were
some highlights from that report that
have been pulled out already as
land and water committee reports but uh
you're happy to take any questions
questions from the floor
no
sandra
yes i just wanted to ask um
you can surface water team i was a bit
confused the logger that's been on the
the salinity logger that's been on the
mandible bridge for quite some time
um adrian was
going to put a new one on and
is it looks like the new one's there is
it and have you got
results coming from it and what about
the ones that the results from the
logger that's been there for a while
because the new one
um
what i'm reading here is um it's um
it's solar powered
um
and the data will be coming
[Music]
off
it was installed in the second quarter
so
um how
when do we get some results and what
about the old one
my reading of that sandra was um
that it would be the next quarter that
the results were so so thinking of the
fourth july meeting then our next
meeting we may well have some data from
that uh recording
and
not really the old one
i
assume both
um but yeah having not had a chance to
talk to adrian directly about it having
just received the data and reading
through but i yeah my my my reading of
it was like was that and certainly that
yeah he's he's hopeful by the look of
that that we will have some data to
report on from there at the uh the four
july meeting
yes thank you there was a
trudeau party was being monitored as
well where do the um where do the
reports on that go does it go to the
trust can it come to us as well
i can follow up on that i
am not entirely sure what's happening
with those reports but no that let's
make it an action point and i can follow
up um with the surface water team
probably in adrian's absence but i can
at least probably answer that question
in terms of where the reporting's going
i would be surprised if
if if there was a reason for it not
coming to the zone committee so so like
yeah i'll assume that that's something i
can follow up on but i'll look to
clarify that with the surface water team
thank you
hey murray i had a question in regards
to the investigation into the nitrate
lag times and i was just wondering what
the progress uh progress of that
investigation was
in reading that through to erin i saw
that
that's i guess it relates to our
previous briefing too doesn't it that's
going to feed into and probably help
with the next
um
stage of the of and particularly the
um yeah the new planning framework and
through into 2024 so
and as as amber's alluded to it should
help improve i guess the
assumptions are upon which that's
based so i i think that probably
we could almost make as a follow-up
action point to
to what we've talked about with pc7
in terms of timing um whilst that's
obviously a specific science question
but yeah a very relevant one i guess in
terms of what we're moving into next
so i imagine amber would be be happy and
have time to respond to that
while she's sort of still covering the
north until we get a new appointment for
for that team leader role
thank you mary
i'd just
like to follow that up erin by saying
it's actually quite a concern to be
honest when
we're pushing hard and everybody's
pushing hard say we need more monitoring
to get that baseline
and we're being told well there's no
progress because we don't have the
resources so
it needs to be prioritized
under it
oh it's disagreed with you there
yeah yeah i was just also going to add
um on page
my 17 and the written agendas uh bullet
point two the investigation into the
private wells um
the district council has um
has asked ecan to come and fund the
study which as you will recall
was a zipper recommendation ecan wdc and
the canterbury district health board
were to jointly fund
a an investigation
and to date only wdc has done that and
we've been limited with um resource to
about i think we're
39 wells in this report
uh trying to get it up to 180 which was
always the
the aim and um the full council has
asked thee can to come and put some
gosh into it uh so that we can get the
sample size up
i mean there is concern as you read from
the report even with a small sample we
are getting three or four wells
that are over the mav uh for um nitrates
and and other bits and pieces so
um with a tiny wee sample it's not not
taking us anywhere we need to
have a wider wider sampler so he can
spin us to contribute
andrew are you still there could you
comment please
uh i i am still
michael um we'll follow that up because
i know we're having a discussion and it
was raised earlier but also about the
that was to do at the monitoring to time
with the plan and science but yeah i'll
follow that up with um
with our science book
thank you and i do hear what i'm saying
and the financial control at the same
time too thanks
yeah oh sorry i just would add that it
is a
uh how to put it kind of a catch 22 at
the moment with everything else that's
on the go
that's that's what's sitting there is
the problem that we'll definitely
followed up thank you
judith just a
small question and my page 18 the last
work point in
gorgeous water cultural layers on staff
commence stream world cup coverage we
can return it to advice on the hingakawe
gathering area
i just want to be advising on where it
is how to grow it how to grow things
what's there
quality quantity it just
just seemed a little bit of a vague
statement and
what we were actually doing
maybe just expand on this next time
yeah i i'm i'm not entire directly
involved but i did certainly follow up
on on that and i don't know if sophie
may have a wee bit more background or or
possibly arapata but yeah
there is a
um i i think you what you've listed
office is
probably covers you know some elements
of where it in terms of location and
scale health um uh
abundance of
of um watercress
in particular locations so um but that's
that's being done directly with uh naito
hariri i think in terms of so i don't
know if
um you'd like to add anything arapata or
sophie with regards to that
no
there was an ecan staff member that went
out and consulted with the rooney and
grabbed some members to do something
yeah
okay
all right
um
so if you i just said one question from
page 12
going on
with the
stormwater monitoring that that you
started last year and began this year
and
some of the water quality
sampling we've done on the urban
drainage network
if
what stage do we get to look at some of
those numbers please
right so there's an annual report
requirement um so it's just wrong euro
that's got the consent at the moment uh
we've done some something of the other
other townships as well just to kind of
get our heads around it but uh rangiora
will have an annual report
that after the 30th of june financial
year will get written up so i'm guessing
around september
october that's when the results will be
ready lovely thank you
cool
any further questions with regard to 3.3
folks
no
so we have a recommendation that we've
we received this update for its
information
and with reference to the committee's
working groups action plan and
engagement priorities in 2022
do i have a mover please
judith second up
somebody out there
oh second death
thanks martha all those in
all favor
all right against
carrie thank you
murray item four committee updates
okay folks how just checking in with
everybody how are we feeling there
do you feel like you need a little break
or proceed on and try and finish a bit
earlier
i think we're
smacking along
okay we'll we'll roll on that probably
suits i'm aware that andrew has to leave
around 5 30 i think today um
and i'm sure if the committee are happy
we might
there's a couple of items that and
sophie would i think like to have a bit
of time
to talk through
a couple of items under committee
updates but
what i might put on first if i'm just
scrolling through my own is is item four
i'm worried i need to i'm going to leave
actually sorry sorry um
yeah i won't have time to go through
those reports anyway so um okay yeah
okay yeah is there anything you'd like
to
add at this point sophie before you
leave
uh
happy happy to take some questions
after the meeting if that helps
okay
that's fine i'll look to tr and i'll
take any any questions that that come up
through the updates
cool thanks everybody okay thank you
sophie
see you sophie
so just while um
andrew and stephanie are with us online
it might be quite good too i know it
will be a topic that the community just
want to perhaps have a wee bit of time
on which is the an update on the
ashirakahuri river the brad river
revival project
and the associated or related
um
rangiora reach public consultation which
is um about to start where has just
started
come on
early april so or 7th of april we've got
a session coming up as well that people
can join so
um andrew should i hand it over to you
to start with just um i guess the first
part is just around the the delay
to
i guess what will become a consultation
on braided river revival
in in time um so
um
i can probably andrew unless you want to
speak to that but just uh and and our
part i may want to it but it i believe
that the the draft the drafting of that
document has has gone through
to naito hariri um
um at present there is
legal action between
or from
here
to ecan with regards
to
the water bottling consent and
consequently
projects like this may take a wee bit
longer until that issue is resolved
through the court so
it may mean that consultation on this is
a little bit further down the track but
um
the the draft document is being advanced
if you like so
i don't know if either andrew or arapata
would like to add to that at all
oh
arapata do you want to say something
first or
well i was just going to play a straight
back
and say no comment
yeah fair enough
yeah
um
yeah that's right
the um
this project as such the the um
uh in the stage one year
that front-end draft has been put via
mkt
to uh knights
and it's uh as i understand it it's
actually will hopefully will be
presented at the next kaitiaki hui um
as such female obviously get their
feedback um there is still quite a bit
of work to be done um particularly in
the river reach uh section of it and
we'll be looking uh not only to the for
the rooney and but there but also
obviously from the zone committee
on that part of rated river's revival as
we move into
um
stage two as such um
but yeah this first stage with with
knight
is obviously very important and we need
to work through that first before going
into the next part
um
that kind of leads into the ranger reach
maybe just sort of open up for a little
bit of discussion because there was some
um i saw some feedback the other day um
that's seeking
uh clarification around the consultation
perhaps in particular with the regular
reach or i think i've just covered off
the
the broader um braided river's revival
um but yeah
there's any further feedback or
clarification that uh that can be
provided by the by the zone committee
questions i'm talking about yet that
you're speaking
[Music]
thank you andrew
judith
the uh the rangiora reach consultation
was simply that there's most i think any
others knew about it was
well i saw it on facebook and it was um
i think it was by the cycling club while
somebody posted it you know so it was
just that there was this major i mean i
knew the work was going on because we've
heard about the river the project the
problem with the trees and the fact
there's a steering wheel being set up or
set up um a conversation with grant edge
before christmas
indicated that there was going to be
consultation but
to not actually hear about it formally
um through the zone committee um just
seems like a great gaming communication
generally i guess
i guess related to the first question
though and the the
sort of high court i think back to the
high court proceedings on works on a bit
but how does that
feed into all the other things that econ
are doing
gonna be talking about water and about
managing water um
a narrow pattern i want to come i want
to
actually take a swipe at this and not
play straight back
there's two questions one is just why
won't become salted and how can we get
better that's history how can we be
better
and consulted on all sorts of things
coming out of the camp and the second
one is what is the effect of
i suppose just just to go
um back slightly on the um the rengar
reach part is that you you're right
judith that there was the
advisory committee set up
which was a joint committee
with
the district council and with
environment canterbury um
and had various members from both those
um on there and that this engagement
plan was put together it was as such
with um covert and such like there were
some gaps and delays and then it's been
yes it has been swung into action um
i appreciate that yes we could have uh
informed you earlier that it's of the
zone committee earlier that i was was
going out um for the this is for the
public consultation part but i do want
to
assure you that the zone committee will
be part of that next phase once we've
got that consultation uh we're coming
back to say is what we've heard
um what are you thinking effectively to
then start creating the the master plan
for that range or a reach part so
that the opportunity i get that your
point is actually more about being aware
of the consultation with public that
piece we could have done better but
you'll definitely have the opportunity
as his own committee
um to
um
to contribute into the into the master
plan and for that matter too if you as
any of you as individuals want to
go to the online meetings then obviously
more than welcome to him put put forward
individual comment on on that yeah
um
with regard to
the other
to be honest
[Music]
don't know what in fact that's going to
have with um with engagement um
[Music]
uh
we
we are of the understanding
um that with rated rivers revival that
we may be able to progress that a little
bit but we've really just got to see
where that where that gets to um and so
it could well possibly have some delays
um
having said that some of the work has
actually already been agreed that will
be
part of braided river's revival and is
already underway so the work that's in
place there obviously is the woody weed
removal
um
there's some work happening as we talked
about in that november time when we
looked at the
um the map of the area there's about
three projects
i can provide the detail of this after
after but three projects around what's
termed as being
boom transition but um effectively is um
[Music]
some wheat control and also
uh there is um
some fish passage work being done down
near waikoku
and then there's also some work being
done with the ashley
rakahuri rivercare group um in terms of
um
and you've this has been raised before
in terms of the lupine um and a bit of a
program that's been put together across
three years
uh across about 60 hectares of um
islands
effectively to see if we can actually
reduce that lupine lupine in a sustained
way
um for the for the breeding colony so
those are sort of three or four things
that
can still continue on
[Music]
but as far as the overall
plan and feedback from braided rivers
revival and that program of work that's
been put together for the rakahuri that
may well end up being delayed um
in terms of uh being progress so we've
got to play that a little bit by air at
the moment see where we get to
thank you andrew
confession
i
just ducked out to get some quinces
drowned in red wine and ice cream and i
come back and i heard judith mention my
name so
[Laughter]
it's an honest confession now
republican okay
that's right um
if i can i was with arapato just i was
just asking how the high court action
might affect the rangiora reach
management proposals or even the
consultation
and
whether you know things you're back and
listening whether my tour area involved
in the regular reach
um well if i haven't really thought
about consequences
just really
just been focusing on us
getting the right decision made by the
courts um
yeah i'm not sure how it would affect
this program but
we always have the the view that
people's properties or protection of
their properties is
pretty much
second only to the health of the
waterways yeah
so um yeah
yeah it's not something i've really
thought about the other consequences
outside of actually the bottling
bottling process yeah
but
worth thinking about now yeah i have a
chat with a few others and
see what their thoughts are
i mean it would be good i mean
given the legal constraints if other
things that are
peripheral
could at least be progressed to
slowly and be brought in if necessary
when there's some decision
oh
i have no comments on the legal system
as processes
you know australia an environment called
hearings and all that into it as well so
yeah
it's
yeah who knows what they're thinking at
the time
yeah i guess we wait to see what the
outcome of the the you know the process
is isn't it really and
um
yep thank you
yeah
uh judith i think there's a question
within your comment there um just so
clear that obviously we're
um working with mkt with naitu hiriti
around braided rivers revival forward
rakahari as a subset of that back in
november uh the chair was written to on
advice of their um two-year team um
regarding the rangora reach aspect of it
so they are engaged in at those two
two aspects yeah
yeah i suppose it's fair to say
um roonanga and
participation and um
anything to do with water processes and
that and water entities has
really come to a dead almost a dead stop
um
i suppose use a bureau that we're about
the other group that started up in
opposition to the three waters and
a number of councils supporting that
that group
that's really strained
relationships between between the
entities and the no
no yeah
um
so and it's really putting a lot of
pressure on those leading those those
those entities and those committees so
yeah
it's
not really
the parks and recreation um project
which is interested in the dry bits
whereas
yeah but drivers
and how they've joined together it seems
a very parks and rec focused project you
know it's what you do
but then again that's the primary
purpose of this uh los angeles
protection of people's properties
i mean every time that every time the
ashley river blows out up at the
confluence of cuckoo it comes right
behind us
here interference wetlands into the
wetlands
you know between lion side road
happens all the time when it blows out
up there but
you know and you've got you've had
landowners up there crying you know
screaming out for protection for the
cans fault but
you know for decades now they've been
the ones that have been refusing to be
in the rating system
so you
know all right um now i think stephanie
has
had to go and pick up that feeling
because she's just going to pass some
feedback on to andrew
that week
later on yeah
just to add to that mike um
it relates to judith's question one of
the um
i guess outcomes of following up on this
ring euro reach is um i i i knew of
stephanie but i hadn't had much chance
to
[Music]
be
involved sorry i was just reading tia's
message to me the
uh yeah i hadn't had much chance to
catch up with stephanie
um with regards to who works primarily
with the rivers team so so one of the
outcomes of of this uh i think um it has
emerged very quickly that consultation
for the rangiora reach but it does mean
that we're a bit more joined up now so
between stephanie and and kim emily and
myself
i will
do my best to
get
a forward plan of what's coming up
particularly from rivers which
we obviously probably should have had a
lot more contact with than we have
in recent times so yeah one of the
outcomes of this i guess is it it's
pulled me uh closer to the rivers team
and
and uh along with kim and emily from the
comms perspective so we'll look to
hopefully be able to give that
um forward um
uh program of what might be coming up
for the committee in the future
yeah murray if i could just jump in
there i think effectively it becomes
part of braided rivers revival which
when that plan's put together
is actually what that program will work
will be
i will send this document through that
um
just gives a bit more information about
the various projects that are on the go
there at the moment so
thank you andrew
covered that fairly well
again conscious of time and
children
erin do you want to
cover off if you're still there the land
care working group in terms of an update
more than happy to take it as reward and
take any questions
all right any questions of aaron hey
lovely
carry on the good work
judah
caroline's probably out there so we
can't really talk to her and then we've
talked a wee bit about monitoring i
think we got the message across here
do you think you want to add to that
um i i guess i just can't really stress
the importance of of actually starting
to do something because
how you know
it seems that it's vitally important for
feeding into the into the plans
but yet we can't get engagement to start
doing the work just to feed into the
plan oh yeah just yeah yeah
that wheel that keeps going around and
not actually starting yes
yep
uh
sandra
yes i just want to endorse that um when
we had that meeting middle of last year
on monitoring um
tim davey uh indicated that internally
in eight can there was this new program
that was going to do all these fancy
things so
we're almost a year down the track now
and have had
nothing further so
andrew murray
um
a memo out to us to see where all that
is because um
you know i understood that um ecam was
working on it and and was going to do
all the things that everybody was keen
to have done and it's just
fallen off the truck
or something
so if you could update us that would be
great
sandra just to clarify sorry that's a
memo regarding
well where the where is ekans monitoring
program that we were told
about when all those groups came
together
it would end
we were advised that you had some fancy
program that was
going to do all these things so
where where is that
yes
recalling now um the uh
the water data program which has
involved an enormous amount of staff
time over the last yeah the last few
years so
yeah that is something um and it
actually probably addresses
one or two
or three action points from previous
meetings that have been raised around
monitoring as aaron's touched on so
um
it's probably one of them we don't have
to wait for the next two months we we
would a memo out just updating everybody
would be great
yeah i'll look to follow up with helen
shaw i mean it's probably one of the
breakdowns of no longer being in the
office together
as staff that we've kind of lost a bit
of that continuity
okay we'll come pick that conversation
up and um sandra and uh aaron and i know
come up elsewhere in this conversation
get your your
this piece about monitoring is a
frequent fire in the conversation at the
moment so i can assure you that it's um
somehow it hasn't fallen off the truck
but yeah i do take the point about um
it's um
[Music]
it perhaps has been forgotten that it's
actually on the truck so to speak here
so we'll pick it up and follow it
through yeah because it it's not just
for you folk it's for others and
landowners and everybody out there that
want to connect with it
and the way that i put it forward and
for example aaron with the um
uh
with the um landcare group is the value
that it has in distributing information
out to a network of people who can make
a difference
thank you
sandra do you want to talk to the land
and water committee
meeting
um
not really um it's all there uh was um
and the debate was
it was live streamed but if there's any
questions anyone has um welcome them
yeah
i think i've just got one in there um
it was around the proposal to use a
sucker truck for the
sediment trap on greens road
yep
um
well they had a screen on it so it
doesn't take out
um it's
it's now come off the cam fund and gone
into the drainage
um maintenance budget um
part of the deal with the cam fund was
that it was a capital works focused
thing um but i can
um so it just comes under drain cleaning
but yeah i i can ask the question for
you i would imagine just like any
any drain maintenance they'll be very um
very aware of um
you know where that trap is it's just on
the corner where the where the waitu
area goes across
um and swaps sides
and heads yeah
yeah um
so the proposal to use the sucker truck
was because they just dumped the
sediment on the side of the road is that
right
they don't take that sediment away they
take it away
yeah they're just having a trial of it
because we have so much well generally
um the drainage rural drainage groups
particularly in the areas where there is
lots of lifestyle blocks um
uh don't don't like the drain cleanings
left on the on the resi on the road
reserve they want it taken away which
and of course the preference and the
um is really to leave it there and if
you've got um
any um
any living things they can go back into
the drain or back into the water course
um and i mean in the past we've had um
uh with
with um
rooney to get um
it was sheree used to do it i think yeah
come out
yeah
and that that's the
the way it's um being we we used to do
it unpaid in the in the 70s and 80s when
they put the drag lines through there
yeah
yeah um but we didn't put them back in
the river though
no no i imagine you didn't but i can
i'll ask what the what the protocols are
going to be i'm just worried around the
timing of autumn that's when the
tournament are heading out to sea
they'll be on the go and they're going
to sit in those sediment traps if
they're a meter or two meters below them
below the bed
that's where the water's the coolest and
it's the darkest and they'll sit in
there
and sit there for a couple of days so
that it's it's prime prime spot for the
eels and they'll if they'll just get
sucked down there if they're gonna use a
sucker truck you won't see them again or
their offspring
well i'll
i'll make i'll ask and get them to get
back to you but um the protocol was to
have always um have someone from united
site
yeah
apparently mkt said she's not a mandated
person i heard the other day but
yeah
it came up it's come up in one of the
rural drainage groups before that um
so she's been mandated along with three
or four others since the 90s
yeah oh yeah indeed indeed i'll ask
again and get them to
yeah
all right no that's okay
i might have a catch up here one day
around that 4.5 proposed fencing policy
it was changed at um
at the committee uh
and i can give a quick um update
the fund will only be used um because
the
approach now is is a bit of catchment
work and a bit of in-stream work because
a lot of the in-stream work
had to deal with the new consenting
requirements under the
nps we've gone for a few catchment works
but basically um
we'll only use the fund when in fact
for fencing
when in fact all the regulatory
mechanisms that are existing uh don't do
the job and we can get a better
environmental outcome
by using um by working with the
landowner
to
set set
or put a fence or set it back further
you get a better environmental outcome
that enhances the river then we can use
the fund but
uh we have brought in um an adventman
from the from ecan to come and talk to
landowners there has to it has to be any
fencing has to be permanent
um and it has to um there has to be a
mou
so there's quite a few things around it
before you would actually
um
use money out of the cam fund to fence
um any areas and there's one or two that
um sophie identified in the report
um
that anna's probably going to go out and
have a look at
now that she's been brought in because
she has
because of the work she's done over the
years has
a bit of
on-the-ground relationship with some of
these properties
that um we're looking at
yeah i mean my preference has always
been for cinnamon trips but
wdc's seem to think they're ineffective
but
i can't see any other way you're going
to remove remove all that historical
sediment
oh and it's not that they're ineffective
it's just that
the really sizable stuff that we would
want to do um
will need a
individual consenting and ecan has
offered all its people to work through
when we have something like that and we
will we
will be doing that for some of them
um
record meeting with jenny
mid last year i think it was
around all of that red tape and that and
um she said just leave it with me and
we'll get it sorted so yeah we haven't
heard anything um well
something did come back to the
biodiversity champions group along that
line
that if we had
um had a project that needed a consent
now
that in fact um ecan staff would come on
board to help
um work through the consent
um so i'm
keen that we actually um do that
cool that's awesome thank you
yeah we just had andrew up sign off
so kim if you're still there if there's
anything you'd like to report from
communications point of view
kioti everyone um no nothing to add from
me i think there is the report in the um
in the agenda but yeah comms ideas
thoughts welcome to flick me or murray
an email and we'll be happy to follow it
up open to all suggestions
any questions
great thank you for your time ken
just related to that mike um with
stephanie having um left to pick up
children and just while kim's on as well
i uh and talking to stephanie she's
obviously
um you might be surprised very keen to
encourage as many people to attend that
rangiora reach um session as possible so
certainly encouraging the committee
members if if you want to send out that
link to anybody by all means please do
or through your networks
all right
murray do you want to cover off points
five six and seven
yes um so i've got the details there
confirmed for this year's zone committee
refresh so we've now worked out um
i guess the campaign for for this year
which we'll see
as you'll see from the uh from the
the papers um friday the 29th of april
it'll open for expressions of interest
and close 23rd of may uh we'll be
looking
to do the the selection workshops in
june
and we've um already booked in
the
um
the round of council meetings whereby
will report the appointments to both
environment canterbury and all the
councils in july and august so
so we've effectively got that schedule
worked out and there'll be some early
communications just promoting that
coming up in late april just before we
get to the opening day so just for your
information uh to know that and i've
circulated that to
through the facilitation team so it goes
to all committees
um
can i just say that at this point that
i'm not going to be putting my name
forward
for refresh this time so uh
um i know i can't remember is it
caroline the other person i'm not quite
you've put an awful lot of time and
effort into this space
over
well it's been a yeah it's been three
three terms now yeah and then with the
biodiversity and the trust i think i've
got some energy there and um as most of
you know i've got this sort of health
problem which is meaning i've got to
spend a bit more time on myself which is
mostly
exercise and
actually not getting stressed so
it seems like a good good time to step
back
thank you thank you
thanks for letting us know judith and
yeah i think we'll look to obviously um
acknowledge real contribution to the the
committee in due course as we move
through into july august but um but i
guess yeah the biodiversity trust
being established um
as a yeah a natural thing perhaps to
step onto and
and focus on
it actually just takes away one of the
things that was in the
wdc report from sophie highlighted was
there is a potential conflict between
funding from the wdc for the
biodiversity trust and zone committee
when i'm actually on you know just sort
of a bit close
yeah john did you want to put your hand
up sir
are you which john you're talking to
yourself john
oh
right
yep cool
i'll even uh give you an ugly shot
um yeah just very quickly i thought i
thought uh sophie was going to talk
about the cam river restoration there's
a couple of mentions in there about doc
i hadn't replied to the consultation now
that's been rectified i chased up
relevant people last week we've had
staff changes and covered stuff and all
that so we have been in touch and uh
i wrote to sophie on thursday friday and
we just got to clarify a couple of
matters but basically doc supports the
project
for the camera restoration
yep that's all i needed to say
we'll keep you on mate and you don't
actually look too bad are you sitting in
your garage
i am
must be your man
out the back motorbikes everywhere beer
fridge in the corner
that's enough that's out there for the
world to hear
[Laughter]
right
unlike aaron carter i haven't had a drop
during the bloody meeting
thank you
it was it was for cooking purposes
[Laughter]
sandra did you want to chip in there or
were you okay
no good
okay um should i carry on michael please
um the next item is just providing those
um links um one to the essential
freshwater package which is it's just a
regular lancole
and that really follows them from what
lakehill
and lisa were referring to earlier that
that's probably a go-to place for latest
information so i assume i'll keep it
there um caroline had made
um reference in the comments to the
ashburton
hakateri shorebird habit tat management
plan which i included the link to um
which is off the braid site so
having followed up with francis mikhail
kenshi she's put a lot of the reports on
the brave rivers
uh on the braid site because it's easier
to find them so um i took her advice and
linked it from there
uh and this caroline has pointed it out
in the in the chat
um just to link you in carolyn um you
know that the fact that in that
management plan that they've taken a
reach approach to how they've done that
monitoring uh looks like something
that's been applied if you like with the
ringy or a reach approach which
um i can recall as we probably all do
like david owen even talked about that
um some time ago as a approach so
there's a consistent element
to both of those management plans but
that
us through the last season in terms of
providing that
um as a link for you all
as a reference document
um there any questions on that if not
i'll go through seven which um we've
partly touched on
um
several of those action points from
previous meetings relate to monitoring
um as we've talked about so
um i think it is something
for me too as andrew's alluded to as
well he's prepared to assist and going
back and particularly around the water
data program which caroline's noted as
well and to look at a more comprehensive
uh
way of presenting monitoring information
to the committee and and possibly then
to the wider public as well but also
providing an engagement point
for the monitoring working group and
uh
so there's a there's several action
points around that
um
we had other requests and around like
the infiltration trench trial
that uh sandra had asked about an
earlier meeting too was one that uh
i guess we were also potentially looking
at when we were doing the field trip
up around the silver stream area so that
might be something that we both can get
a bit of commentary on but also
maybe get to actually go and have a look
at i believe the project's effectively
completed now
in terms of that work that was being
utilized into plane change seven but um
that could be part of
if we haven't you know in
in may or june if we go and have a look
at the silver stream if covert gives us
a bit more flexibility then that could
be incorporated
um
that judith had asked about the die off
of trees in the light zone draid um
adrian would have been my go-to for that
so look i'll again
look to follow up the science to see
if there's any kind of um
investigation or follow-up that can be
done
in adrian's absence at this point
um
so
again that's me talking to the science
team
um
from 31 january we've also got um
following night actually prior to that
sandra has also touched on that the
realignment of the north brook tributary
which adrian actually provided some
update
um in the the zipper reporting
so
again i guess that's related to the
sampling so it might be that fourth
quarter zipper report where we can
actually look to follow up on on some of
the
the report the monitoring that's been
set up around two thai party lagoon as
well and
northbrook trib
again that i guess the first from 31 gen
that was again probably another one that
i know adrian had spoken to previously
because he had been following up with
neewer with regards to
i just thought that actually
requested an update um it's not a demand
that i want to know what they're doing
it's just that there was work underway
and we haven't heard anything about it
so perhaps to insert an update on the
work rather than
yeah
yeah so that might be even something we
do under the progress
so yeah i certainly um again it's
probably one of the things that still a
little bit with adrian
who who was the primary contact from the
science team following up on that
um
the next one with regards to the the
spraying close
close to the edge of the treatment ponza
and talking to sophie
judith she had mentioned she'd followed
up with you on that i've just got her
email here which is um
they really only
this is from
the engineer that um
for those reasons ie and they've got to
at least spray the track tops we only
spray the bonds where the weeds we don't
want
and if they become overgrown and messy
you know unfortunately plants get messy
engineers don't like that and such the
dead material starts to float and block
the wheels and screams etc so um there
they are they do
take some consideration it's not just a
blanket
it's funny but i think this fact that
and certainly
has displaced the program of it with
them so that's good thank you
thanks judith um
so i was just checking the the comments
as well but um yeah the
the
um now sandra sorry the the earth and
septic tank study by esr now that was
that that was probably when lee was in
the room as well was that something that
we have so or i should follow up with or
probably lee's
former colleagues at esr rather than me
who's now at deer in zed but is that
something that
you'd still like me to follow up on
oh i think so i mean i think we could
all benefit from understanding what um
what other science is going on in our
patch um
and i'd be really keen to to know
exactly i mean clearly
well i don't know that's clearly but i
would assume that
the
idea behind or the
behind that study is whether in fact
it's polluting groundwater
to a significant degree and
contributing to
nitrate levels and in groundwater and
surface waters so
i mean
i'd i didn't know it was happening and i
i'd like to know what um the outcome was
well i found out okay
because i happened to just one of those
bbq conversations with bronwyn who's one
of the authors of that well with the
scientists working on it and she was
very excited about the idea that it
actually got onto a park private they
were working on private property in a
normal septic tank just to see what the
effects are
and so i'm sure she and she was very
keen to come and talk to us
great so
well we might follow up on that judith
in terms of it from in terms of
your barbecue connection and
following
um but yeah that no that that sounds
fine and obviously yeah i guess we're
we're potentially still looking to catch
up with lee
if we do go out and do that silver
string which is a different but related
connection point um just to the work
that esr
uh have been doing in that area as well
so so now okay we'll
we'll follow up on that and possibly
towards a briefing as well from
uh in relation to that item
possibly at the july meeting
uh and the final two items were um
uh is the um what i've included above
which are from caroline with
making note of the the ashburton
hakatiri shorebird monitoring plans or
management plan so we've
included that link and um and then
i guess what we've talked through
from the previous meeting of wanting to
have
an update on raider river revival so
given what we've talked through earlier
um it is where it's at and we'll
obviously keep that
on the radar and look to be um following
through on both the immediate
consultation already reach and then the
braided river revival program as it
develops throughout the year so um
we'll keep that
um
on point really for us as we go through
the the coming meetings or as sandra
noted before if we can have something at
a workshop session between before
meetings then um all well and good
we'll certainly do that
so i think that's the update michael
has any
final questions it's probably just the
recommendations for that one
no
i think we're all there um just a note
aaron harvey just had to sign off so
thanks to her
time
so
we've gone through those updates thank
you murray for those
so we have a recommendation for
4.1 through to 4.7 that the zone
committee received these updates for its
information and with reference to the
committee's working groups action plan
and engagement priorities in 2021
can i have a mover please
judith thank you second up
john thanks
john crop
all those in favor
okay
all right against
carrie thank you
item five
confirmation of minutes
from the previous meeting of the 31st of
january 2022
right so let's um
have a recommendation there
that's right
sorry just
my brain is slowing right down we can
move that recommendation and then
ask if there's any changes is that
correct
that is correct
yep thank you
so
rick the recommendation is that
the zone committee confirms the minutes
of our meeting held on the 31st of
january 2022 as true and accurate can i
have a move up
[Music]
against
carrie is there any matters arising
for alterations
um
just one chair um regarding the
presentation by michael bates
um
when he talks about toxins captured in
uh river sediment
um
then caroline commented the test done
approximately five years ago indicated
the pesticide levels in the river were
non-lethal
however this information seemed to be
outdated i'm just wondering is it
worthwhile last getting that done again
um but
that way at least you know we can say
we've done that here's the results and
um take it from there with michael
yep
i would fully enjoy endorse that arapata
um
i think we do owe him some action i
think this is you know this would be a
good starting point for you yeah
sandra is that something we could take
up with somebody in your team
um
i can um it's usually uh that's ecan
stretch of the river um down down from
bramley's down and um
he can does all the monitoring and
testing um
the sediment
i i'm just trying to um
understand the chemistry of what happens
in the lower cardboard because of the
high nitrate and it's over the
mps levels
um that in fact it
i'm trying to remember the chemistry of
how it works
basically
it keeps all the
all the pesticides and any organic stuff
in in
in solution basically
so you you don't get it deposited in the
sediment
um that's what happened when there was
the last test and it's going back um
a decade or more ago now when they did
the
uh sediment testing for when they um dug
out under the tuhoy um for the birth at
the at the wharf
but i mean yeah there's no no reason why
um you you couldn't do it again it's
been done a few times but basically it's
always um surprisingly clean
because of the chemistry of exactly
what's happening in that river um that
you don't get um
you don't get it in the sediment
but
but i mean
it's just a suite of um
i think ecan has done it traditionally
because they just have the expertise and
i remember being in a boat
um
with one of the ecan guys
going up the river at various points
taking
sediment samples
from below the what was the old wharf up
to the confluence of with the cam and
further up there
but um
that was
yeah that would that would be a part and
parcel of when there was the consent
applied for um dredging under the tuhoe
so that's a decade ago
um
i guess but yeah i mean
ask
ecam would be the request um i would
suggest goes to
and and certainly i i think there would
be support from
the district council as well
thank you
um
murray could you take that up with
adrian meredith perhaps just to see if
yeah i probably in the short term won't
take it up with adrian but i'll i'll
certainly add that to my list of
requests of the science team so i'll
follow up with um
uh
um
shirley hayward
and uh amber cool and put it down so
yeah no that's fine
popping on andrew apps is less too just
yeah
yeah no that's that's fine i think yeah
that's um i'll
especially as sandra's highlighted there
may well be yeah well there obviously is
some precedent for for that monitoring
work that they might be able to work off
and repeat
all righty
any other masses
lovely i think we're just about there
folks
and they've done that done that arapata
would you be so kind as to finish this
off with the carrick here
then i'm going to have a second helping
okay
uh unuh
uh he's had a um
a stay of operation i think is the right
way to put it he's
so he's actually going to be
he's got a wee bit of time um
where he's actually been able to i guess
contribute to a wee bit of work as
you've seen
[Music]
you